♪♪
-In Surprise Inspection
this week,
we did a lot of jokes
about the planet Uranus,
and a bunch of you said
that's not how that planet
is pronounced.
If I had pronounced
it a different way,
my writers would have
gone on strike again.
I opened the last episode saying
that I was not a boomer.
Bungee pointed out
I still did a Jimmy Stewart
impression and made a Who joke.
Very...
What started as a kind comment,
I thought,
about my
Jimmy Stewart impression,
and then took a turn.
"That Jimmy Stewart one
is out of this world.
I can't recall a time
that I have heard one
where absolutely none
of the basic elements
of what makes his voice his
were used."
[ Imitating Jimmy Stewart ]
"Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hey, there."
Ooh, this one was bad.
I guess, uh...
I did the Pete Townshend
windmill backwards.
He famously did it like this
to end up.
And I did it like this, but I
was told that was on purpose.
NBC said we can't even afford
the residuals for the motion.
I had to do a look-alike.
Here's another nice comment.
The last "Corrections"
was our 90th episode.
"90 tries, no good jokes
or interesting stories.
Let's see if something changes."
Yeah, man. By all means,
stick it out.
You obviously got a lot
going on.
Well, obviously, on episode 90,
we're not going to do a big
thing for the 100th episode.
A lot of people are asking.
We did for the 50th episode.
We did a SpecJackular.
And I stress that it was not
an episode of "Corrections."
It was a special,
a pre-recorded variety special.
And then we submitted it
in that category for the Emmys
and received a letter
from the Academy saying,
"We don't consider this
a special,
because it's not any different
from the other episodes
of 'Corrections.'"
And to the Academy, I say, fair.
Got us dead to rights
on that one.
We tried to pull a fast one.
You caught us. Congratulations.
Also, congratulations to
"I Think You Should Leave,"
which did win
the Emmy for this category.
Fantastic show by our friends
Tim and Zach.
[ Light applause ]
You know, you could also
applaud for "Corrections."
[Bleep].
Like, the whole time,
I'm like, "Oh,
they just must never clap."
Biden said "a book of fiction."
I called him out.
I said, "That's called a novel."
A lot of you said,
a book of fiction
could be a novella
or a book of poems.
I personally,
I only read nonfiction poems.
That's just me.
You might think it limits them.
It doesn't. The nonfiction
limericks are worse.
No one from Nantucket
has one that long.
I said Alaskan Airlines.
It's Alaska Airlines.
It used to be "Alaskan,"
but then during a flight,
the N just blew off.
Just landed in a field
in Nashville,
which used to be Asheville.
Someone said, "There are
very few pizza delivery men
in porn anymore."
That comment was sent in by...
Anonymous.
Had a joke about
peanut allergies
in Surprise Inspection.
Then we showed an insulin pen
instead of epi pen.
We knew the joke
was about peanut allergies.
We just thought it was so bad,
it would give
the audience diabetes.
Oh, I referenced the motorcycle
I was going to buy this weekend,
and I said how excited I was
to finally be able to go
"vroom vroom vroom."
I guess you don't do both
at the same time,
because only one
is the accelerator.
I was told if I did this,
"the bike would likely fly out
from under him,
raking his legs as it went,
pulling him along
like a ragdoll."
I might pay to get both
be accelerators.
I've got two-accelerator money.
Oh, I was also told I don't
have to make the "vroom vroom."
I guess that's included.
Ooh.
Talking a lot about pandas,
whether they eat meat or not.
Um, pandas, here's a comment.
Pandas are actually
"what's known as
a facultative herbivore.
They do better on a plant diet,
but can eat meat.
There is a video of
a giant panda chasing, killing,
and eating a peacock in a zoo."
Now, obviously,
when I read that,
I quickly went to YouTube,
because I wanted to see
if that was true.
It is true. I found the video.
We're going to show the video.
I should warn you,
it's fairly graphic.
It is what it says it is,
so if that's not the kind
of thing you want to see,
maybe skip this part
of a panda eating
and killing a peacock at a zoo.
Alex, do you want to show it?
[ Peacock cawing ]
[ Panda roaring ]
♪♪
[ Splattering ]
A court stenographer
doesn't use a typewriter.
In my defense,
it is hard to remember
the name of the machine
they use.
A stenographer
doesn't use a typewriter.
They use a stenograph.
I should have said "stenograph,"
or if I wanted
to keep "typewriter,"
I should have said
the court typewriter-er.
I said harakiri wrong.
I hope I'm saying it right now.
I said, "hare-kare."
I believe it's "hara-kiri."
I have dishonored myself.
If only there was a way...
Someone wrote this.
Someone, "Seth,
not exactly on topic,
but I thought you should
know that your image,
along with Kelly Clarkson's,
is fraudulently being used
to sell a product
called Pure Balanced Keto.
I will attempt to send
a screenshot
if I can find an appropriate
email address to send it to.
Sue the bastards and keep up
the great work
with 'Corrections.'
It's the best."
Thank you
to whoever sent that in,
and also thank you
to Pure Balanced Keto.
Ever since I've started
taking it, I have more energy.
I sleep better, I feel better.
Isn't that right, Kelly?
And then just, like,
cut her in, laughing,
and then just
send me my [bleep] money.
Showed an ornament of a...
It was a Steeler
with the Mac Tonight head,
and it said 12:37 on it.
And I initially said, "Oh,
somebody was trying to guess
the length of 'Corrections.'"
And then somebody said, "No,
it's actually a Bible verse."
And I looked up
the Bible verse,
which is very apt to
"Corrections."
And then last week
100 of you said,
"No, you dip[bleep].
It's what time
your show starts."
That was definitely it.
The last one I got to.
Did a joke
about the kind of fake eye
Ellen tried to get me to show.
It was a bloody eye with
the nerves coming out of it,
and I said, "Can you believe
she wanted me
to show this on TV?
The nerve."
A lot of you said that was --
I mean, that's
an A-plus joke, right?
That's why you come
to "Corrections."
And someone wrote,
"Bravo to whoever wrote that."
I wrote that joke.
To quote Jo Koy, "I write
the ones you laugh at."
That would have really
rang true for me.
I turned 50 over the break.
An interesting thing happens
right before you turn 50,
for the weeks leading up to it,
people are like,
"Oh, my God, are you excited?
You must be so excited.
Where are you doing
on the big day?
I can't wait to hear.
I hope it goes well."
And then you turn 50 and no one
talks to you ever again.
It's like you're invisible.
It's like you're
a ghost, walking.
I went to the automatic doors
of the grocery store.
They didn't even open.
[ Chuckles ] In that joke,
I go to the grocery store.
Can you imagine?
"Where's your milk," I guess.
How do you say it?
Hey, I did turn 50
and, you know,
we got that P.O. box
that we set up,
and received
some really lovely gifts.
This is a fantastic.
I got some
Animal Flubs finger puppets.
Look at those. Beautiful.
That's a really great gift.
Thank you so much.
Also,
I will say we did a very long
"Animal Flubs" song
the last "Corrections,"
and I think a bunch of
you hit your breaking point
and asked me
never to do it again.
And so that is
a New Year's resolution
is no more "Animal Flubs" songs.
I want you to know,
I heard it loud and clear.
I don't know
if this is really from OSHA,
but have you ever heard of OSHA?
That's the Occupational Safety
and Health Administration,
and this is,
"For your safety and
the safety of those around you."
And it is a pencil
with a cork on it,
because a lot of people --
we talked about
how I'm almost going to
take my eye out,
so I'll be using that
from now on.
Thank you very much.
We got our 3D printer friend
and he made me, um --
this, by the way,
you should really look away.
The panda thing was a joke.
This is actually distressing.
He said, "I sent you
a Meyer lemon."
[ Audience groans ]
It's very, uh, flattering...
emphasis on "flat."
Oh, and then,
someone said there was a...
Amber did something about
how she wanted her own Barbie.
And someone
sent this in for Amber
with the loveliest card.
And, you know,
when I was looking at it,
I couldn't help but think,
"That's not what
my P.O. box is for."
Okay?
If Amber wants a P.O. box
to get gifts,
she can set up her own P.O. box.
It's not that hard.
You just go to your assistant,
you go,
[Whining] "Will you
set up a P.O. box?"
Oh, and then,
this is really special.
You guys know
I'm a Steelers fan.
The camera crew got me
an autographed
Lynn Swann jersey.
Look at that.
Here's the autograph,
it's on this side.
Lynn Swann, if you don't know,
was a wide receiver
from the Steelers
who weighed 800 pounds.
Just so graceful,
and they got my size, 5XL.
I'm going to have --
You know how many more years
I'm going to have to work
to afford to frame this?
This is like if David Byrne
was a wide receiver.
I am a boomer. [ Laughs ]
Oh, and chewing --
We've been talking about
how I chew my fingernails,
and that's another
New Year's resolution.
I've tried to stop
chewing my fingers,
and we'll keep an eye on it.
Let's take a look
at how I'm doing.
-♪ Animal flubs, animal flubs ♪
♪ It's time to take a look
at some animal flubs ♪
♪ From the birds to the bees
to the baby bear cubs ♪
♪ It's time for animal flubs ♪
-♪ And I know, you don't
need to say "baby" ♪
♪ Before you say "bear cub" ♪
♪ Because in that case,
"cub" means "baby" ♪
♪ But when you're writing a song
on a Thursday afternoon ♪
♪ When you really should be
working on "A Closer Look" ♪
♪ Sometimes you're gonna cut
a few corners ♪
♪ In order to make
the rhyme scheme work ♪
-♪ Animal flubs, animal flubs ♪
♪ I hope you're all ready
for some animal flubs ♪
♪ Call all your pals,
bunnies and pups ♪
♪ It's time for animal flubs ♪
-♪ Are the five letters ♪
♪ Used ♪
♪ To spell "flubs" ♪
♪ Animal flubs ♪
-I made the crew
come in at 8:00 a.m. for that.
See me next week.